[Music]
on today's show we talk about being
terrified to go outside after all the
mass shootings
we talk about being stressed and fearful
in every facet of your life
and we talked to a woman who had an
ex-boyfriend who's dating somebody new
and she wants to know should she call
the ex's new girlfriend and tell her
everything
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with a doctor
john colony show i don't even remember
the name of the show
we'll just get right into it listen i'm
coming from being on another
show just a minute ago a big show with
millions of listeners i'm all nervous
and i said the word drowning
drowning not a word drowning
is that right my editorial linguistics
i don't know let me ask my ten-year-old
child
i so i said they were drowning and i was
trying to be clever
and it's like you're gonna feel like
you're drowning and to which everyone in
there was like
nope we're not cause it's not a real
thing idiot how many doctors do you have
idiot well thanks a lot jimmy and
james and kelly feeling hurters that's
not the first time we've corrected you
on that specific winning oh my gosh
listen by the way well you can put it in
my annual review
rude heartbreakers i think i get it i
get why people say that because some
people just
say that and i think it's because you
say he drowned
she drowned but but it's because there's
the ed on the end some people just
assume it's drowning but
it just is a pet peeve man we talk about
pet peeves on the show
i wanna thank you for trying to make me
feel better
and make me feel not stupid just dumb
so thanks man no not stupid or dumb just
just an idiot it's like yeah i don't
like
drowning or people who listen to lint
biscuits still that's james
you know you are the one who controls
how you feel not me
[Music]
oh yeah starting on this show well to
you how about that james childs how
about that
and to all the people who are fighting
back with the horse
noises we're getting your emails i mean
can i hold on in all of the
calls we've taken the sad things we've
talked about the
horrific things we've talked about on
this show we've gotten
more emails regarding the horse noises
and the pushback against james in
particular listen
about the horse noises it's crazy we
have an audience of people who know
when they see tyranny and they see you
two trying to run this show
and all i'm trying to do is help people
and you two with your grammar police
and the professionals is that what
you're talking about your your equine
noises
police your animal noises what kind of
ship are y'all running back there oh we
got to say everything the right way and
use
all real words and we're only going to
use
human noises instead of in whatever
okay you literally have a rocket
diarrhea sticker on your mug on the show
so i'm pretty sure that we're not
clamping down too hard on
professionalism here
is the i'm so glad you joined us on the
dr john dolone show if you want to talk
about your mental health
your uh relationships do you have
tyrannical bosses too
well i got a show for you this one
so much so that i named it after myself
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 and
if you're struggling with where you work
and who you work with i feel your pain
we can do a whole segment show on that
let's get right to the phones so we're
no longer drowning
let's go to marissa in dayton ohio
what's up marissa
how's it going hey dr john thanks for
taking my call thank you
hey is it drowning or drowning
um last i heard it was drowning hmm
thanks for kicking me while i'm down
marissa real cool
wow one for team kelly thank you yeah
thanks for going so what's up how can i
help
so i'm calling today with a concern that
i feel like
a lot of americans have right now about
just the anxiety over the mass shootings
recently and just the fear of going out
in public going to the grocery store and
um it's just it has me really anxious
and
when i'm in the grocery store i'm in and
out as fast as possible and i'm looking
around
at everybody like they're a threat and
it's just not a sustainable way to live
and i just
wondered how you thought we should go
about handling that anxiety
hey thank you so much for that call
marissa i'm grateful that you called
because you're exactly right
everyone i know is wrestling with it and
struggling with it and thinking through
it
and um it's an unsettling
feeling it's unsettling time right let's
just be honest with it
so the best way i can answer that is to
tell you directly how i handle it
is that okay i don't have any major
scientific studies or anything like that
i can just tell you what i'm doing
personally
um and i'll also tell you i've responded
to
actual scenes of gunshot victims i've
been in there i've helped clean those
scenes up i've helped move them those
body it's
i've been there and so i i know what
the with that i just
i have an intimate knowledge that i know
what it's like and so
when i see some of these things they
will set off my alarms all our brains
are trying to do is take care of us
right
and the more we feed at this stuff over
and
over and over the more
our brains start looking for it because
it wants to keep us safe
and what we've entered into with our
media world and i don't want to blame
media because these things are really
happening
right but they're not happening at every
grocery store they're not happening at
most
grocery stores they're not happening at
the vast majority of grocery stores or
schools or colleges or fill in the blank
but we have a media system that is paid
simply on how many eyeballs it gets how
many clicks it has
and so it has a vested interest in
pumping that information into our brains
any shape form or fashion and on top of
that
every person's got a camera now and
some of the justice oriented things
those cameras have been lifesavers
literally right
it's helped us see justice it's helped
us see another side of a story that we
never would have received
in other times it just gives us 84 new
angles of the same trauma and so these
media outlets are just recycling and
replaying all these different
clips our brains are registering these
clips all of them different
and it is just saying don't go to school
don't go to school don't go to school
school's not safe school is not safe
and all media is trying to do is just
get us to keep watching we can't we
can't turn our heads away from it right
and so yeah first and foremost i just
cut the media off
i cut it out i have very few people that
i
plug into anymore um and they're folks
that i i value based on trust
and um i can hear about it i don't need
to watch it i'm pretty selective about
what i choose to see
because i know my brain is going to do
its job and when it sees
something it's going to set off a system
of alarms and chemicals
and mechanisms to keep me safe and
sometimes it overrides
my thinking part of my brain right and
so if i hear about the latest school
shooting
in state x y or z
almost never am i going to plug in there
and go watch what just happened
almost never because i don't want that
in my head
it was a few years ago i checked the
data recently but i did a
presentation for a group of college
professors after one or two
high-profile shootings at colleges and
interestingly at the time the data said
the safest job in the united states of
america the job you're most
the least likely to get killed at while
doing it was a kindergarten teacher
the next safest job was a college
professor
college instructor yet if you were to
have watched the news
my colleagues were like man we're next
right and we're gonna we're getting
often record numbers the data said
actually you're safe
it was the sensational coverage of this
of media over and over and
over now we've seen a spike in shootings
no question about it
right but is it going on every single
place everywhere
it's not it's just not and so what
you've got to deal with is the reality
that it could happen
and the reality that it's probably not
going to happen
and the best way i have found is to stop
indulging the click fast stop
indulging all the drama to be vigilant
to be smart now i also found myself
i've been trained for some of these
situations and i've been trained to
get out of some of these situations is
that going to keep me safe probably not
right but you know you can know to look
for it but i don't even think that's
necessary i think being
aware and vigilant and then recognizing
the data is on your side
so i want to ask you give me an example
like you go to a store
and you mentioned you're out just
scoping people around what are you
looking for what do you think you're
gonna see
uh i mean i'm just looking at people
looking at
looking to see if they look
i don't know like they're holding
something
or like they're just looking suspicious
i don't know really what i'm looking for
i'm just in and out as quick as i can or
i do click lists
um yeah but i am definitely guilty of
reading everything i can about every
shooting that happens
i just let my brain get lost in that
information
so here is a really fascinating thing
our brain does
when let's imagine back in the old days
um and you you may have heard me say
this on the show
a bear shows up at the front of your
cave right you and your family are
snuggled in there nice and warm in a big
pile
and a bear shows up you're you see that
bear
and your brain does not want you
thinking i wonder if that's a nice beer
is that our friendly bear that comes
around
is that oh that's the s the funny bear
it just has one rule run right or if you
can't run
fight grab sticks and uh rocks and if
you can't fight or run away
we're gonna shut the system down and
you're gonna freeze you're gonna play
dead and maybe he won't mess with you or
maybe he'll just drag you somewhere else
and give you a chance to escape
somewhere else right
when your brain goes into fight or
flight it
unhinges it unclicks your rational
thinking brain
it unhooks it and it trades accuracy for
speed what does that mean just what you
described
it's how a police officer who gets a
call on the radio
somebody running down alley armed and
dangerous
fired off shots and their heart starts
racing
they get out of the car and they are
worried about their own safety
and then somebody with a cell phone
right because your brain says
close enough let's make sure you're okay
or you're in a grocery store and you see
somebody walk by and it looks
kind of sort of similar to somebody on
the news and they're holding a
box of macaroni that kind of looks like
a whatever
boom you clench your purse tighter and
you run out of that room
right so here's a way to combat that
number one
you're right turn off the news fight
that impulse
to just absorb all this info and by the
way
a lot of my friends absorb that info all
day and then they turn on some
murder podcast and or they watch and i'm
looking at you kelly
they turn on some murder podcast and
then they go home and watch law and
order svu for the 21st season or
whatever it is right
that's just all they consume 24 7.
and what you look for your brain will
find
yeah right and so when that's all you
consume everyone is a creep everyone's a
criminal everyone's about to murder
everybody
here's the other thing you can do
besides turn off that nonsense
you can intentionally spend time
talking looking with people being with
them at a grocery store
saying hi how's your day going to people
standing in line with you
and listen when you first try this your
heart will beat because you'll be
nervous
and then hopefully the front part of
your brain will stop and go
is it so ridiculous that i'm nervous in
line at a grocery store
right and you'll realize oh that's just
a tired dad trying to buy some chicken
for
right or that's a tired mom who's you'll
realize that
99.9999 of people
are lovely and kind and just trying to
get to the day too
so it's a decision to i'm gonna slow my
breathing down
so my brain works i'm going to look
somebody now and say
a long line huh or how's it going or i
love your shirt
or are you having a good day right just
slow
entry-level communication and by the way
you throw a year away at a pandemic
right
and that's made it all worse now
everybody can get us sick and
kill us and all those things on top of
it right so
um not only are they going to shoot us
they can just breathe on us and it's all
over right so we are
at apex fear level
heightened heightened heightened and
people are getting shot
they are getting shot right we've had a
number of shootings right in a row in a
row in a row
um and unfortunately we're going to keep
having i mean
it's it's just escalating
um but you the reality is the data says
most of the time most of us are safe not
only are we safe
but we're surrounded by people who are
good folks who love us
and everyone's just kind of waiting on
everybody else to go first
and so it has become a a spiritual
practice of mine a mental health
practice of mine
to look people in the eye to smile extra
big
make sure people can see my hands at all
times this is stuff my dad taught me as
a little kid
to make sure i'm kind and make sure i'm
asking people how your day is
i would say seven or eight times out of
ten when you're going through a line
and the woman at the counter the man at
the counter is just
is going beep beep you know like uh
ringing your food up
and you just say hey how's your day
going they will
pause they'll freeze for a second
because they'll snap them out of their
mindless dull job and they'll look you
know and say i'm doing all right
or not super great right and you can
share a laugh
a quick moment of humanity there but
marissa at the end of the day
the data tells us that most of us are
safe most of the time and it's our
choice to go looking for beauty
right and if you are in a situation if
you are in an environment that is
more dangerous if there's been more
shootings in your area
then i'm gonna advise you to go take a
class i'm gonna advise you to
um go be wise go meet with your local
authorities and say hey we're worried
about this area what are some things we
can do as a community
um but chances are we're making ours not
chances are
for sure we are stressing ourselves out
we're much more likely to die of a
stroke or a heart attack or some sort of
inflammatory disease because we're
living in this heightened ruddled stage
than we are being shot okay or driving
too fast or
tripping on the way out of the grocery
store because we're trying to get in and
out so fast
slow down breathe deeply look people in
the eye
regain our humanity one hello hey once
you go ahead of me
go ahead and go first let me pick up uh
if you got the money i'm gonna pay for
her groceries
one at a time at a time thank you so
much for that call marissa you're
awesome i appreciate your heart there
all right let's go to kyle in louisville
kyle what's up
hey john it's awesome talk with you how
are you hey man i'm good
too and i didn't say louisville i'm
proud of myself it's
lovely oh i'm not from here so i'm
it's the same way i say louisville and
everybody looks at me weird ah
okay good team deloney all right so hey
you don't say drowned
all right we're done with that all right
so what's up man
okay um so i struggle with like stress
or anxiety or whatever you want to call
it really bad
i get stressed about everything some
large some not
like i mean i think it comes a lot from
like always going top speed and having
so much to do
and working in a high stress high octane
job
i get stressed about like getting out
the door on time in the morning when i'm
waking up early enough
i get stressed that the work i do is not
good enough even though i know it is
i get stressed about bad drivers and
just everyday things like that and then
i get tense and angry and my blood
pressure gets high
yeah and my girlfriend who works in the
medical field
is recommending that i look into an ss
into getting prescribed onto it like an
ssri
and she struggled with a lot of these
same kinds of things and her doctor
recommended it and it's worked great for
her
and i'm just kind of unsure about it and
looking for advice because i know you
say a lot of times like
you know all this stuff is just alarm
systems and i don't know if it's good to
mask it or
if it's or whatever so well man i
appreciate your vulnerability here
um somebody who struggles with control
it's hard for them to be vulnerable so
i appreciate you reaching out man um i i
can
hear in your voice this is not an easy
call to make how long have you
been working to control everything in
your world
my guess is since you were little yeah
my whole life
i mean i think i get a lot from my dad
it's just like okay
i've always kind of been like the guy
who takes leadership in most roles and
i feel like i am a good leader but then
it's when i put in roles of
non-leadership i
i struggle because you want to take it
right right what is if you
were to um evaluate you on your
leadership performance what is something
negative that somebody who worked for
you would say about you
um probably that i'm not always the best
at like implementing other people's
ideas and stuff
like i definitely like to take and
listen to other people's ideas and
implement like
pieces and parts of it but ultimately
probably just try to keep it as my plan
still okay
but with maybe some of their ideas okay
so
this this um stress this frustration
that you feel
um it's ultimately at the end of the day
and i take a lot of flack for this but
um kyle i'm you
i've been you most of my life and
to feel this way is a choice
and i hate to say it that way because
i'm this is the pot talking to the
kettle here
until i spent some hard hard time
putting space in my day realizing that
the best roi of my time was actually
going to sleep
the best roi of my time was sitting with
other human beings and listening to them
that my value was not about what advice
i could give and what
thing i could muscle through and clinch
and flex
and pump through
and it took years brother for me to get
that message through my thick head and
i'm
still wrestling with it but what you
find man is your heart rate goes way
down
you're way more patient on the road you
drive the speed limit sometimes even
which sounds crazy
right i actually find it's a pretty
calming thing to do sometimes
it is right and i'm like in the slow
lane
yeah and listen you feel like you're
doing earth a service by following the
law
right can you imagine like
50 years ago the idea of going 70 was
like a rocket ship and now that's what
you're doing to calm so
that's a temporary a temporary move
right
my guess one thing and this also like
leads into is like i've been
thinking about making a job change
because my current job is like
6 a.m to 8 p.m it's 100 travel all the
time and i never get to have a community
and so i'm looking
at making a switch to a job that's
settled somewhere
with my girlfriend that i don't have to
travel all the time and it's
calmer hours more normal hours and they
like really work
focus on work-life balance where my
current one doesn't and hey kyle listen
i absolutely 1 000 support that but
here's the one catch to it
whatever new job you get you're gonna go
with you
no matter what job you get what salary
you get
somebody calls you out of the blue and
says hey i want you to mow my neighbor's
yard
i'm gonna give you 250 000 a year and
you'd be like really what else that's it
kyle's gonna go with you
and you are going to turn whatever new
job you get
into into a third rail electrified
fence for you and everybody around you
because that's that's the energy level
you operate at
because in your soul you believe your
value is based on
how fast and long and hard you can go
and somewhere somebody whether it was
your old man or your mom or your friends
or a combination of whatever ecosystem
you grew up in
told you that rest is for lazy losers
and income income performance
go that's how we're gonna that's what a
man does right
that's how you get it that's how you do
it go go go
and you're right you're gonna make a lot
of money you can be on the road and you
can crush it and kill it and devour it
and then
um last i looked men lead
planet earth in money and wealth and
accumulation
and men lead earth and cancer stroke
heart attacks and on and on and on
right right we are proving and achieving
ourselves to
death
and so my question for you is
where did you hear for the first time
that your value is in what you did
and how fast and how far you went
man i don't know it's just is that
lifelong thing
of is it ringing true you know yeah
so listen to me kyle how old are you
27 just recently 27.
so here's my guess by 35 you'll have
some sort of weird physical thing if you
don't already
it'll be a really weird thing in your
neck your knees are going to hurt
something's going to be
physical on you are you already there do
you have a thing
yeah i've gained a lot of weight because
of stress and work and stuff like that
and now
everything hurts okay
and so your body's hollering at you
we're not okay
right right
and here's the deal that girlfriend
loves you or she wouldn't be trying to
come up with solutions she would have
just bailed on you it's pretty cool that
you have her in your life
here's what an ssri will do here's what
it did for me
it will slow the alarms down so that you
can actually do the work
you can actually sit down and meet with
people you can go talk to a counselor
you can
if you don't want to go sit in the
presence of somebody which i recommend
you can i've got a partnership with
betterhelp right you can get online and
get a therapist that way
but it will help you slow down and do
that work
it is not a solution long term and most
people
take it and then they it allows them to
ex
stay at or accelerate their current pace
how much weight have you gained in the
last few years
like 130 pounds yeah
what's the end road for you
what do you mean you're 27 what's
uh 45 year old kyle looking like
not physically but pay me a picture more
than anything i want to be
i want to be like a good dad and husband
more than any like career aspirations
but like
it's hard for me to pull myself away
from it how come
i don't know it's the you know tell me
if you're not moving you're dead
kind of saying yeah if you're not if
you're not moving you're dying
right yeah so i want to tell you this
like if you waste an hour in a day or
something like that you should have been
doing something
else there you go there you go
and so you're listen man you've been
redlining that machine
for 20 years now
and i'm telling you i work really hard i
work real hard
and i was up at five this morning
exercise like i'm all about work hard
okay and i won't go to bed until late
tonight and i'm working on a book at the
hou like
i'm all about working hard but i also
canceled an event at somebody's house
tonight so i could go sit at a baseball
game
and so i could go have dinner with my
family and i'm not saying i'm great dude
i'm still figuring this out myself
but i had to build in time today with be
with people and i've got a phone call
after this show's over
right you got to build it in it's got to
be part of your life and it starts with
you valuing kyle
and right now you don't you're running
brother you're running you're running
you're running
and here's what i want to tell you
you're worth a good night's sleep
you're worth an exercise routine you're
worth eating well you're worth that girl
walking in and hugging you so tight you
can't breathe
and i want that for you kyle so bad way
more than i want some
you to get another sale or another
whatever it is you do
okay okay so yeah if if
going to see a psychiatrist is gonna
help but i don't want you to put a pill
in your mouth until you work with that
psychiatrist to get a plan
for how long you're gonna do this and
it's gonna have to come with a lot of
behavioral modifications
choosing to change the way you live
okay okay there's something
there's something you're not gonna do it
though huh
i want to okay so why aren't you gonna
choose it i can hear it and you're gonna
be like all right bro cool and you're
gonna hang up and you're gonna be like
that sucked and you're gonna have like
two beers tonight and then tomorrow
you'll be back at it
no i mean like i definitely want to do
this i just don't know where to start i
guess but i mean
looking for a psychiatrist will be the
first part all right here's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send you a copy
of my redefining anxiety book i'm gonna
send to you for free okay
stay on the line and kelly's gonna mail
it to you okay okay
and um i want you to commit to me today
before you go see a psychiatrist i want
you go see a counselor okay
actually you know what if you've gained
130 pounds in last year too don't you go
see a medical doctor
okay you got a lot going on and i want
you to sit down and tell somebody
um not your physical symptoms i want you
to tell them i'm not okay
i'm tired of running and running and
running and running
and i want to make some lifestyle
changes and
if the doctor says well we can just give
you a pill for that i want you to go
say well no thank you and go see another
doctor okay
okay i want you to find someone who will
listen to you and we'll talk with you
and we'll say hey we're going to give
you some medication if we need to but
we're also going to connect you with
a counselor and we're going to get you
on a plan because this is a
this is a a absolutely solvable
challenge
and you're up for it if you put this
much energy
in the energy you put into staying alive
and making that next sale
into being well and whole dude you're
gonna be the greatest dad
ever you're gonna be the most
extraordinary husband of all time
and then you know what your business
wins will come comically easy to you
because you're doing it from a platform
of sleep and wholeness and wellness in
relationship dude
okay and what i'll tell you is when i
was your age i got called in
um maybe a little bit old uh maybe 34 35
i had a buddy who was a college
president and i i wanted a job
and he called me and said i can't hire
you because you're electric
you're a tuning fork in every room you
walk into you're just
his exact words where you're too
volatile does that sound familiar to you
yeah that's actually been written on one
of my uh reports once ta-da
now fast forward a few years i'm the
calmest guy
of my friends know okay so i want to
stand out there and say
it's hard work but you're going to get
there but it all starts with you being
able to look in the mirror and say i'm
worth getting well
and i'm telling you guys as a guy who's
never met you you are 1 000
okay well no still like hearing you on
the radio now
like knowing if you were like this it
would i mean that's definitely a plan
that i want to follow and do
that's awesome brother that's awesome
awesome awesome
it starts with you look in the mirror
look at that girlfriend of yours tonight
tomorrow
i want you to look her in the eye and
say i'm ready to make some life changes
and i'm so grateful that you've stuck
with me and i've been hard to be with
for the last few years
today things are going to be different
starting today
we're going to go for a walk after
dinner tonight
and then in the morning i'm not gonna do
some crazy workout plan but in the
morning i'm gonna get up and i'm gonna
write five things i'm grateful for then
i'm gonna go for a walk
and then i'm gonna make an appointment
with a doctor a local doctor she works
in the field so she can hook you up with
somebody good
and you're gonna start a journey of
taking a left turn in your life man
and i can't wait i want you to call me
every step of the way
every time you're down 25 or 50 pounds i
want you to call me
every time somebody cuts you off and you
bow your head and you say a quick prayer
for them and say i hope they're getting
to the hospital soon
instead of swearing god cut me off
i'm going to get a bigger truck so
instead of just going man hope they're
doing okay
i want you to call me every step of the
way as you turn this thing around
get people to walk with you so grateful
for the call brother kyle
thank you so so so much
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today all
right we are back and hey look i want to
take
an email that we got and it caused some
discussion here
in the office and um so here's the
here's the email it's from shay
shay writes i recently got out of an
abusive relationship and my ex is now
dating someone new i approached her and
told her
about his abuse sex addiction and
cheating
so shay approached the new girlfriend
and said hey
um i'm gonna tell you about his abuse
sex addiction and cheating
she says she hasn't experienced these
issues and is staying with him
should i do more to try and convince her
or is there a possibility that their
relationship could
actually be healthy so when i read this
my first thought was
what are you doing don't go to your
ex-boyfriend's
new girlfriend and start running him
down except the thing she was running
him down
was about abuse and also his infidelity
and sex addiction
so my first thought was
yeah i guess their relationship could be
healthy
if he actually was an abusive person
whether and it doesn't say what kind of
abuse so let's say emotional abuse and
he was a sex addict and he was a cheater
yeah those are probably gonna show up
again those behaviors unless he just saw
the light one day walking down the road
and um so i guess they could be healthy
my bigger challenge is this you don't
get a vote
it's not your relationship shay you
don't get to speak into
your ex's new relationship with somebody
else
and i know that's so hard to hear
but you shouldn't be calling her right
um she says she hasn't experienced these
things that she knows of
that's not your that's not your
responsibility you got to go quietly
into the night
and go find somebody else what do you
all think
so if it if it is a like actual
i mean abuse is abuse but say it's
physical abuse and it's something pretty
serious
yeah and you know that and they're
they're dating somebody new like what
what responsibility do you have if any
like
you just kind of sit back and so if
somebody was
physically unsafe right i would call the
police
and let them get involved in that and
say hey i was harmed by this person this
person is now with somebody else and
the police would do a welfare check and
go check in on that person
i can't i can't wrap my head around
calling an ex's
new person and being like hey just so
you know does that make sense kelly
you're not guys
i mean if they're like in the maybe
they're in the same friend circle or
something like that yeah
it wouldn't yeah maybe that's it maybe
maybe she's friends with
the other person too as a female i would
say
if i had dated a guy especially if we're
talking physical abuse
physical abuse feels different yeah it
feels different
and he had physically abused someone
previously
i would want to know that either through
the ex calling me
or if we had a mutual friend that we
could call because my thought reality
the police aren't going to do anything
nothing's happened
they don't have time so i would want to
know that because i would
that's information i would need to know
before i decided to stay
if the if there's possible physical
abuse
what about hey he's a cheater
sounds like i wonder if she cheated with
him like on you
if how would that call go hey i want you
to know that this guy cheats
and she would be like yeah i super no
because i was the other person
well i took that i did the email so i
know that that was there was overlap
between the two of them oh
okay and she did let her know that but
she made the choice to stay but i
wouldn't think
that you would necessarily need to call
on that but but when it's physical
safety
and it could be somebody's life yeah so
yes you took that to deathcon that she
ended the email
by saying or is there a chance it could
work it sounds like she's just trying to
get
in their business that's when i read it
i felt like hey i just need to let her
know that he's not very nice don't say
sorry your relationship with him is over
he's an ex right now
this whole thing gets messier if they've
got kids together or there's some other
you know they share a house together or
something like that i think we took one
of those calls once where
we broke up but we're still sharing a
house but
yeah i do agree if there is a chance
that somebody's not safe you gotta let
somebody know
right you gotta make that phone call but
at the end of the day if you break up
you broke up right and someone has
addictions or cheating
i'm gonna say stay out of it and keep
your relationship
go get with your yeah
i don't know i mean i really wish i was
talking to shea in person here because i
have a thousand different questions here
but yeah mind your business
i wish i had another nicer way to say
that but mind your business sound good
mind your business yeah
that's the kind of great uh radio
coaching i get from the producer i think
this is why we don't do email questions
a ton because
it requires a lot of digging in so yeah
there you go
well way to bearfundruiner.com.net.org
james childs
i happen to love this uh email question
shae thank you for writing in
if you have any more email questions
write to johndaloni.com
show do not put the ww in front of all
that because you don't even have to
because it's
20 21. go to john delaney.com show kelly
will pick it up and if it's a great
email
and she can somehow get it through james
then we'll do another email on the show
so so glad you wrote shay that's a messy
one man
yeah mind your business all right we're
gonna end on today's show
oh my gosh on what a s what an
incredible song
i can just play it
dude
oh my goodness 2001 off the incredibly
titled
be not nobody lots of negatives going on
in that one
vanessa carlton comes up with the
masterpiece
i can nail that on piano was that the
one piano song you learned
to try to get people to think you're a
great piano player yeah
yeah um vanessa carlton's a thousand
miles and i don't care who you are or
what you are
this song is good and if you're a metal
head and you love pantera i don't care
you love this song too and if you're a
country music
savant you love this song too and if you
love yourself some hip hop
you especially love this song too and it
goes like this
making my way downtown walking fast
faces past
and i'm homebound staring blankly ahead
just making my way making a way through
the crowd
and i need you and i miss you and now i
wonder
if i could fall into the sky do you
think time would pass me by
because you know i'd walk a thousand
miles i could just see you
tonight such a great pause
and it's always times like these when i
think of you and wonder if you ever
think of me
because everything's so wrong and i
don't belong living in your precious
memory that's a good line right there
vanessa
because i need you and i miss you and
now i wonder
if i could fall into the sky do you
think time would pass me by because you
know i'd walk a thousand miles
if i could just see you tonight
[Music]
this has been the dr john dolone show